مرحبا بكم
من قناه الجزيره هزت انفجارتنا عنيفه
للعاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف ضمن موجه جديده من
استهدفه مدن عده وافادت السلطات في كيف
بان القصف الذي تم باستخدام قاذفات
الاستراتيجيه وقطع بحريه ومسيرات اسطر عن
مقتل شخص واحد واصابه 13 بينهم الصحفيون
ياباني
جديد جديد
تنتصر في الحرب
في المقابل اتهم رئيس الروسيه الغربه
بالكذب والنفاق بشان المساعي لحل النزاع
في دباس
ان العام الماضي كان عامل قرارات الصعبه
وان الغربه اراد استغلال اوكرانيا لاضعاف
روسيا وتقسيمها
كده نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ان العام
القادم لن يكون سهلا وقال انا اعداء روسيا
سيحاولون كسرها ويخضاعها وان النصر سيكون
حالف بلاده
نقلت رايت رزان وسائل الاعلاميه كوريه
الشماليه زعيم البلاد كيم جونغ اون امر
بتطويره صواريخ خبر الاستيعابره للقارات
تتمتع بقدرات هجوميه نوويه مضاده وذلك
خلال اجتماع للحزب الحاكم
صاروخان قصيره المدى فوق البحر في الساعه
الاولى من صباح يا اول ايام العام الجديد
حسب التوقيت المحلي وفقا لهيئه الاركان
المشتركه لكوريا
اقل من 24 ساعه على اطلاق بيونغ ثلاثه
صواريخ بالستيه سقطت جميعها في بحر
اليابان فقالت السلطات الكوريه الجنوبيه
استفزاز خطير يجب ان يتوقف واكدت القياده
الامريكيه في منطقه المحيطين الهندي
الدفاع عن اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه بينما
اكد اليابان وانها صدد تطويره الصواريخ
بعيده المدى بحلول عام 2030
نقل مراسل الجزيره في افغانستان مصدر
امنيا ان 10 اشخاص قتلوا اصيب ثمانيه في
تفجير عند المدخل الرئيسي للمطار العسكري
ووسط العاصمه الافريقيه كابول
نقلت وكاله رويترز انجوين رئيسه تايوان
قولها ان الحرب ليست خيارا لحل المشكله
والسلام والاستقرار في مضيقي تايوان وفي
خطاب مندي مناسبه حلول السنه الميلاديه
الجديده عبرت المسؤوله الاولى في تايوان
عن استعداد بلادي هذه المساعده الصين في
التعامل مع غيرنا
مشاهده شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]